nunca antes vistos por la humanidad.
Hasta ahora, nuestra respuesta no es adecuada.
Pero ya lo saben.
Tienen la corazonada, lo sienten en el cuerpo.
Somos parte de los sistemas vivos del planeta,
unidos con casi 7700 millones de seres humanos
y 1,8 millones de especies conocidas.
Podemos sentir las conexiones entre nosotros.
Podemos sentir el quebrantamiento y la ventana de cierre para curarlo.
Esta tierra, nuestro hogar,
nos dice que debe surgir una mejor forma de ser, y rápidamente.
En mi experiencia, tener los ojos bien abiertos
es tener el corazón partido todos los días.
Es un dolor del que rara vez hablo, aunque mi trabajo requiere el poder de la voz.
Me recuerdo a mí misma que el corazón simplemente puede partirse
o puede abrirse.
Un corazón partido y abierto está despierto y vivo, e invita a la acción.
Es regenerativo, como la naturaleza,
recupera el terreno arruinado, y crece de nuevo.
La vida se mueve inexorablemente
hacia más vida, hacia la curación, hacia la integridad.
Esa es una verdad ecológica fundamental.
Y nosotros, todos nosotros, somos una fuerza vital.
En vista de ello, el vínculo principal entre las mujeres, las niñas
y un mundo que se calienta
no es la vida, sino la muerte.
Crece la conciencia de que los impactos climáticos
afectan más a las mujeres y las niñas,
dadas las vulnerabilidades existentes.
Hay un mayor riesgo de desplazamiento,
mayores probabilidades de sufrir heridas o muerte durante un desastre natural.
Una sequía prolongada puede precipitar el matrimonio precoz
conforme las familias se enfrentan a la escasez.
Las inundaciones pueden obligar a la prostitución como último recurso,
ya que las mujeres luchan por llegar a fin de mes.
La lista sigue y se amplía.
Estas dinámicas son más severas en condiciones de pobreza,
desde Nueva Orleans hasta Nairobi.
Demasiado a menudo la historia termina aquí,
pero no hoy.
Otra verdad empoderadora pide salir a la luz.
Si ganamos terreno en la equidad de género,
también ganaremos terreno para abordar el calentamiento global.
Esta conexión sale a la luz en tres áreas clave:
tres áreas en las que podemos garantizar los derechos de las mujeres y las niñas,
reforzar la resiliencia
y evitar las emisiones al mismo tiempo.
Las mujeres son las principales agricultoras del mundo.
Producen entre el 60 y el 80 % de los alimentos en países de bajos ingresos,
a menudo lo hacen en menos de dos hectáreas.
Eso significa ser “pequeña agricultora“.
En comparación con los hombres,
las pequeñas agricultoras tienen menos acceso a los recursos,
incluidos los derechos sobre la tierra, el crédito y el capital,
capacitación, instrumentos y tecnología.
Cultivan con tanta capacidad y eficiencia como los hombres,
pero esta disparidad bien documentada en recursos y derechos
significa que las mujeres producen menos alimentos
en la misma cantidad de tierra.
Al cerrar esas brechas
los rendimientos agrícolas aumentan entre un 20 y un 30 %.
Eso significa entre un 20% y un 30% más comida del mismo huerto
o del mismo campo.
Las consecuencias para el hambre, para la salud,
para los ingresos familiares, son obvias.
Sigamos el hilo conductor hacia el clima.
Nosotros, los humanos, necesitamos tierra para cultivar alimentos.
Lamentablemente, a menudo se limpian los bosques para abastecerla,
lo que provoca emisiones derivadas de la deforestación.
Pero si las granjas existentes producen suficientes alimentos
es menos probable que se pierdan los bosques.
Así que hay un efecto de onda.
Apoyar a las pequeñas agricultoras, lograr mayores rendimientos,
evita la deforestación y mantiene el poder vital de los bosques.
El proyecto Drawdown estima que abordar la desigualdad en la agricultura
podría evitar 2000 millones de toneladas de emisiones entre ahora y el 2050.
Eso está a la par con el impacto
que puede tener el reciclaje doméstico a nivel mundial.
Abordar esta desigualdad también puede ayudar a las mujeres
frente a los desafíos del cultivo de alimentos
conforme cambia el clima.
Hay una fuerza vital en el cultivo.
Por último, a 130 millones de niñas
se les sigue negando su derecho básico a asistir a la escuela.
Las brechas son mayores en las aulas de secundaria.
Demasiadas chicas están perdiendo una base vital para la vida.
La educación significa una mejor salud para las mujeres y sus hijos,
una mayor seguridad financiera,
un mayor campo de acción en el hogar y en la sociedad,
una mayor capacidad para navegar por un mundo con un clima que cambia.
La educación puede significar opciones, adaptabilidad, fuerza.
También puede significar menores emisiones.
Por diversas razones, cuando tenemos más años de educación,
normalmente elegimos casarnos más tarde y tener menos hijos,
por lo que nuestras familias terminan siendo más pequeñas.
Lo que sucede a nivel individual se suma en todo el mundo y con el tiempo.
Uno por uno, el derecho a ir a la escuela
repercute en cuántos seres humanos viven en este planeta
y en sus sistemas vivos.
No es por eso que las chicas deberían recibir educación.
Es un resultado significativo.
La educación es una cara de la moneda.
La otra es la planificación de la familia:
acceso a servicios de salud reproductiva, voluntarios, de alta calidad.
Tener hijos por elección y no por casualidad
es una cuestión de autonomía y dignidad.
Sin embargo, en EE.UU., el 45 % de los embarazos no son intencionados.
Doscientos catorce millones de mujeres de países de bajos ingresos
dicen que quieren decidir si quedan embarazadas y cuándo,
pero no usan anticonceptivos.
Escuchar las necesidades de la mujer,
atender esas necesidades,
promover la equidad y el bienestar,
esos deben ser los objetivos de la planificación de la familia, punto.
Frenar el crecimiento de nuestra población humana es un efecto secundario,
aunque potente.
Podría reducir drásticamente
la demanda de alimentos, transporte, electricidad,
edificios, bienes y todo lo demás,
reduciendo así las emisiones.
Zanjemos las brechas en el acceso a la educación
y la planificación familiar y, para mediados de siglo,
podremos encontrar mil millones de personas menos en la Tierra
que si no hacemos nada más.
Según el proyecto Drawdown, mil millones de personas menos
podrían significar que evitamos
casi 120 000 millones de toneladas de emisiones.
En ese nivel de impacto,
la equidad de género es una solución importante
para restablecer un clima adecuado para la vida.
En ese nivel de impacto, la equidad de género
está a la par con las turbinas eólicas,
los paneles solares y los bosques.
Hay una fuerza vital en el aprendizaje y una fuerza vital en la elección.
Ahora, seré clara.
Esto no significa que las mujeres y las niñas
sean responsables de arreglar todo,
aunque probablemente lo haremos.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
La equidad de las mujeres en la agricultura,
la educación y la planificación familiar...
son soluciones dentro de un sistema de soluciones de reducción.
Juntos constituyen un plan de posibilidades.
Y permítanme ser aún más clara sobre esto.
La población no se puede ver aisladamente de la producción o el consumo.
Algunos segmentos de la familia humana causan un daño exponencialmente mayor,
mientras que otros sufren una injusticia demasiado grande.
Los más ricos somos los más responsables,
tenemos más por hacer.
La relación entre el género y el clima va más allá de los impactos negativos
y más allá de las soluciones poderosas.
Las mujeres somos voces vitales y agentes para el cambio en este planeta.
Y sin embargo, demasiado a menudo estamos ausentes
o incluso somos excluídas de la mesa proverbial.
Con demasiada frecuencia somos ignoradas o silenciadas al hablar.
Con demasiada frecuencia se nos pasa por alto
cuando se establecen planes o se hacen inversiones.
Según un análisis, solo el 0,2 % de los fondos filantrópicos
van específicamente hacia las mujeres y el medioambiente...
casi USD 110 millones a nivel mundial,
la suma gastada por un hombre
en una sola pintura Basquiat el año pasado.
Estas dinámicas no solo son injustas,
sino que nos están preparando para el fracaso.
Para remodelar de forma rápida y radical la sociedad,
necesitamos todas las soluciones y todos los solucionadores.
Cada mente, cada pedacito de corazón, cada grupo de manos.
A menudo anhelamos un simple llamado a la acción.
Pero este desafío exige más que una hoja informativa
y más que una lista de verificación.
Necesitamos funcionar más como un ecosistema,
encontrando fuerza en nuestra diversidad.
Sabes cuáles son tus superpoderes.
Eres educador, granjero, sanador,
creador, activista, guardián de la sabiduría.
¿Cómo aunaremos fuerzas para que las soluciones avancen?
Hay un papel que quiero pedir que todos desempeñen:
el papel de mensajero.
Este es un momento de gran despertar.
Tenemos que romper el silencio en torno a la condición del planeta.
Ir más allá de los debates fabricados
sobre la ciencia del clima
compartir soluciones,
decir la verdad a corazón abierto.
Enseñar.
Pero para hacer frente al cambio climático,
debemos hacer realidad la equidad de género.
Y ante un desafío aparentemente imposible,
las mujeres y las niñas son una fuente feroz de posibilidades.
Es algo magnífico estar vivo
en un momento que tanto importa.
Esta tierra,
nuestro hogar,
nos llama a ser audaces,
recordándonos que estamos todos juntos en esto.
Mujeres, hombres, personas de todas las identidades de género, todos los seres,
somos una fuerza vital.
Una Tierra.
Una oportunidad.
Aprovechémoslo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)